Так. Всіх Вітаю, усю чудову п'ятницю. Ми наближаємося до Літа до кінця.
Нашого курсу, і як то кажуть: до гарного завершення ну давайте сьогодні спробуємо зробити не просто гарним а чудовим, павло гладкий.
Так. Всім. Доброго дня. Загалом сьогодні як Сергєєв вже зазначав на лекційному Занятті.
проблеми.
Boost still. The balance.
Звісно, Звісно, можу вам почекати.
Декілька хлопчикам поки станіслав приєднається крас можливо, ще інші приєднаються туди.
Вас навчитися героїч?
Перепрошую, якраз Максим. Приєднався так що чудово.
Так.
Мене. Чесно.
Так чинити?
Зараз.
Як бачимо екран.
Ну ось дивіться в мене вийшла трошки під'єднатися з сервер я все потусав по папком щоб було зручніше клієнт все по папках попав добавив ось у мене сервер крапка.
Гри.
Є, нові але Воно все працює. Воно не надсилає. Але не надсилається. Не зберігається.
Інформація з логіну. Регістром тобто це трошки складно для мене.
пайл, конексен крапка. Джаз Він другий з даху. Так Тобто, ось це фактично є основа за допомогою якої ви можете під'єднатися до вашої бази.
Угу.
У.
Є і зараз переднісу.
Так, чи є вас встановлений Монтегбі.
На комп'ютер чи?
Виписували Імпічмент від того в Москві Ні.
Давайте перевіримо повністю так, наче.
Ми можемо спробувати ще раз, якраз пести це не буде зайвим, тому.
зазначаємо за допомогою процесу N і тут назва на мангкодіпій її орел у вашому випадку, я бачив що вона трохи інакша тому треба змінити її під бій-оре або змінити ось тут і ту що є у вас то файлі крапка Енз.
Ні.
Так. Ось ця Бачите, друга вас банкрутство. Можете, скопіювати цю назву.
І замінити. Тоді ні не значень, так назву назву і замінити тоді Манка Депійорел з вашим Тобто це вже буде заміна на вас тоді от і тоді ще 1 момент вам тепер треба спробувати під'єднатися до бази даних в сервер крапка.
А Оце ні.
Єс для того, щоб це зробити вам потрібно загалом, отримати цей файл яке ви тільки що створили прийдіть сервер на джиґас.
Так і Тепер хтось і вам відправив ось наступний рядок десь можна поставити після. Сьомого рядку скажемо е це фактично отримає.
Підключення до нашої до нашого файлу, який ми тільки що створив Добре. І Тепер вам потрібно буде створити ще одну змінну десь після ось цього восьмого рядку напишіть лет створимо нову зміну і назвіть хай буде Дібі.
Ну.
Вам треба зміні. Дібері.
Назначити значення таке типі як функції Тобто це викликати ракети все було приправно і дорівнює так кетпі ні ось та те, що ви бачите, на восьмому рядку ми зміну створили.
Так.
Ні.
Так. І Відтепер дошки.
Так, і тепер Бачите, вони нас. Повертають проміж тобто це синхронна праця Тепер єдиний момент.
Для завершення нам потрібно По-перше, додати парикет дібії. Слово Евейт.
Для того, щоб чекати Ей Табою, Е.
Спершу має бути ай.
Аа Ей на неї Бют.
А Так.
Ось бачите вам пропозицію поставили Тут пробіл. Треба так і тепер на 20-му. Рядку бачите у вас там є в кінці рядка.
Рожеві рожевими вони введені фактично перед стрілкою.
Дошки на двадцятьм рядку.
На 24.
Так і перед ними. Перед цими дужками, вам потрібно писати Ес.
Кого всім.
А А 7.
Ось так добре і давайте тепер спробуємо запустити тобто зберігайте нам чесно встановлений.
Так. Так.
Так. Виник А от, Кейшин Проба Феєлд Е чи у вас правильний Користувач.
Вона написала.
Був тому що виглядає. Те, що воно не може під'єднатись бачите у вас тут є, ви вказали користувача. Але ось воно вказує після цього тачлантів, діб і паспорт замість цього тобі паспорт вам треба буде казати пароль, від користувача, якими вказував.
Угу.
А до цього воно було напевно.
І треба прибрати знаки більше. Менше. Перед після бачення Зберігайте і Давайте спробуємо ще раз.
Зараз в мене просто від безумовно, тут мінюшко зараз непіку кудись ребрацію.
Все добре.
Так все ще бачу проблему і вона все ж та сама правильний пароль тому що там пароль вимагає від саме користувача, бази даних з'явиться з комерцією того ви можете відкрити мандарію можемо глянути те саме.
Як створене.
І вам треба буде піти в доступ то це секюрики ось тут також збоку нижче, там дати тебе і секс.
Так бачу користувач є впевнені, в тому що пароль коректний був.
Той що ведений якщо ні, то можемо Загалом, можна його змінити.
Експерти зараз та й секули.
Краще спробувати встановити пароль.
Пані зараз. Зараз. Не треба дописати все наче.
Добре, Давайте спробуємо ще раз.
Зараз буде нормально.
Так бачите помилки, не видала І в все тоді працює.
Тобто Далі ви можете просто використовувати вже 2 метод для підключення до онлайн-купії і виконання операцій.
Ну.
Дивіться Ось, в нас логіка та зареєструватися як кнопку в нас є такі постанови тому наприклад, якщо зареєструватись, там наприклад.
З.
Зараз.
Ну, використовувач зареєстровано воно нам відповідає.
Як Тепер зробити так, щоб воно у нас сахаринилось, базу даних що воно вже зберігається.
Чудово.
Ні. Вам потрібно його зберегти Дивіться, тут залежності від того, в якому вигляді можемо в найпростішому вигляді його спробувати зберегти власне-таки, це можна зробити досить просто.
Перше. Вам треба повернутися в онкодібє Тут натиснути кластер з боку Так. Найвідвертніший Так.
І тут браузов легше бачите, у третій кнопка трошки.
Так. Бачу основну пропоную вам треба надати ет-майон Дайте додати власні і ось нам говорять що треба вказати ім'я бази даних.
Можете вказати демонстрацію тут яке.
І так далі. Ім'я колекції а тобто таблиці фактично це буде ідентифікатором, для того, що там зберігається Ну, бачимо можна користувачі наприклад, щось загальне от і це вам не треба це додаткові налаштування, і створюємо.
Може посилати на посади чи ні.
Ти.
Так бачите ось у вас створилась монстрапедія користувачі Добре. Тобто, тепер ми можемо повернутися до коду.
Угу.
І загалом так можете відкрити сервер крапка, єс у вас там я бачу, на реєстрації.
Ну.
колектив і вам треба вказати ту колекцію То таблиці когось створено вашу випадку це була юнус.
Тобто, вірус зараз?
Добре. І тепер ще 1 момент можна поміняти місцями ось 17-18 рядок.
Щоб відповідь, від сервера відправляли вже Після того, як ми там спробували додати користувача так можете перезавантажити сервери і можемо спробувати додати якусь хусточку і перевірити чи подекуди воно взагалі працювати.
Так. Це воно.
Так бачите ось на нові відправи можете повернутися е можемо перевірити чи були то 1 якісь дані бачу, що даних, немає в мене є, підозра що вона намагається підключитися до неправильної бази даних, можете відкрити знову сервер і ми оглянемо що так консолід нам нічого не видала так?
Тоді можливо.
Так. Поверніться в Конгрес. Будь ласка. Крапка Чес.
І ось тут бачите нам треба змінити назву базу даних у моєму випадку це була ні.
Аплікейшин але у вашому випадку це монстро-педі, на восьмому рядку тобто змінюйте її так, і також з великої букви, щоб реєстр співпадав.
У.
Добре, тепер перезавантажити і давайте спробуємо ще раз.
Добре, Давайте спробуємо ще. Раз, глянути? Чи додалось? На щось прозонне бачите, але наскільки я бачу що даних, немає Тобто, мабуть все ж таки є, проблема, з тим, щоб відправляєте, до сервера.
То їде.
Тобто воно не не підхоплюєте може можете показати, як ви робите запит до серверу.
Не розумію, чому.
Ні в частині коли натискається кнопку зареєструватися.
Зараз ось Мене.
Ну це мене В цілому.
Плюс.
Ну, мабуть, те, що на.
В рядку 50 сьомому як під результат, реєстрація ее так Хіба що я підозрюю, що дата ось цей щось створюється мабуть, воно не заповнюється мабуть, все ж таки в цьому проблема.
Все.
Що ці дані про не заповнюються ніякі вони відправляються пустими вже того, до сербер так Тобто Ось ці дані вам треба буде перевірити у чому проблема чому воно не заповнюється власники.
За все.
Ну ось навіть зараз ну що в реєстрації в регістрі ось ми вписуємо в інституті текст це у монологін па пароль думаю, тел і воно все сюди в принципі йде.
Так, можете трошки вище показати форму.
Ось все формачка логіну ось регіста я можу Так, зробити.
Ага. Так.
Органів, налагоджувальне виведення щоб не просто що успішно зареєструвалося а вивести відповідні поля, що ви отримаєте.
Так це також може спробувати я думаю, що?
форми та наскільки я пам'ятаю, її можна вказати самі, Тобто, куди воно запит робили автоматично ее.
У кнопка санкт є опрацювання, відповідно нічого до неї не прив'язано наразі.
У порошенка.
Але ймовірно, форма опрацьовується нижче.
Після наприклад, 49 рядка.
Можете написати?
Щось по типу консольло?
А аляр алярд він використовує так, щоб без проблем.
А Так. Кожная. Аледа.
Ну.
І Давайте спробуємо.
Формат. Давайте спробуємо поки що форм, дати, гляньте що воно Взагалі отримає в дужках, і в дужках.
Що фарб дату.
І давайте тепер спробуємо.
Ще раз оглянути що в нас відбувається.
Добре Це не спрацювало. Тоді, мабуть, треба нам консольлог робити тому що інакше тоді можете повернутися, будь ласка, її замінити алерр на консоль крапка.
Лог трошки можна полегшити але вже у відома Так, і тут форм дату казати.
А вам.
Чи то вперед, це сервер можна не перезавантажувати в випадку, плє еге це треба запустити Але якщо ви змінюєте лише контент частин Тобто, дизайну то север собі може працювати вільно, від цього так?
Перш ніж робити запит натисніть я в 12.
Аско так ось тут буде е відповідно. В нас показуватися результат того що ж ми отримаємо.
Я ще перечитав сторіночку. Тому що фронттен доновлюємось.
Так. Ось воно. Вивело так, бачите Тобто, форм дати.
Просто немає нічого тобто вам треба буде переробити цю частину тому що Ну.
Не знаю.
Ще раз, помилка в чому те, що воно в простоформі знаходиться.
Так? Тобто, форма вас фактично майже ні.
Кажучи, у вас форм, даєте це якийсь метод, якого я не бачу.
Тобто, він не зрозуміло, як у вас сформується фармтей і ті фармдей.
Доброго дня. Перегляну.
Вже.
прикладу можете глянути підха припозиторії. Там у нас Ось мейнеч Ти мав.
Бачите, Тобто наприклад, для на шостому рядку для для юзер найма для реєстрації я вказував простоюзернею Тобто як пароль і вся логіка перенесена у тест крапка єс це останній файл.
1.
І ось тут бачите, у нас перший метод точно так зверхуюсь як я отримав п'юзернем і палива просто документ ні тобто ви таким самим чином можете, спробувати зробити воно цілком має спрацювати.
Г.
Форму ви можете лишити як таку події, також це цілком дієвий, спосіб просто що отримання.
Але просто додавати і отримати їх незрозуміло.
Так це буде простіше, і тоді вона має цілком працювати тому що ви бачили що до бази даних дані додало просто даних тих немає.
Дляген.
Добре, зрозумів. Дякую.
Тоді будемо працювати.
немає це Фактично, розділ чогось на сторінки, Так, можна запитати: технологічно Навіщо нам це взагалі потрібно А про тебе ми не можемо не використовувати ми можемо відображати для користувача.
Все ще бачить найпростішим випадком. Є Наприклад, будь-який блог. Якщо відкривають, табло то ви бачите вас а все ж вантажить став мій показує кількість сторінок, звісно є більш хитрі методи пагінацій.
сторінки, у стилі, генеруються нові пости які ви можете також дивитися і у випадку наприклад, з тим же інстаграм, або будь-яким блогом, ви можете бачити що проблема якщо ми скажемо для одного блоку є 5 000 різних постів, відображати їх на сайті є не дуже гарною ідеєю, по декількох
завантажуватися і 10 секунд, що не є дуже добре тому в цих випадках ми хочемо використовувати пагінацію.
Так я зараз пишу екран, і ми можемо тоді почати з власне розробку бк частини, яку ми поки що розглянемо.
Добре, збільшує трохи край. І давайте поки що зменшу концерт, в нашому випадку, спробуймо створити альтернативу користувачам оскільки в нас є юзерс з фактично способом, оригінацій що нам 500 треба По-перше, для того, щоб робити поєднання нам треба декілька базово вхідних
стороні і коли користувач кнопку для того, щоб отримати другу сторінку, було і по-друге це та кількість даних, яку ми хочемо, отримати.
Ну, може варіватися. Це може бути 5 до осіб це може бути 10 будь-яка кількість, яку ми хочемо розпочнемо з цієї частинки, і давайте створимо я просто скопіюю вас ось тут.
Скажімо.
Не закрий тобто перше нам треба отримати від користувача.
функцію. Яка називається пар сніг вона просто там вартує рядок були числом і далі ми така ж само робимо для розміру стріну я підсунув цю зміну пич сайз і покажемо ось тут.
Так і вич добре Тобто ми Таким чином, можемо з вами розробляти.
Що саме надходить після того, як ми отримали дані. Нам тепер треба все ж зробити запит до.
Мандодібi і складемо найпростіший фірма Користувачі і будемо використовувати тіпні тут можемо казати став іги легше.
Йозеф тепер Схоже, до того? Що у нас було ми вказано Пайг у нас немає будь-яких умов.
По яким ми хочемо знаходити, пости поки що не будемо ускладнювати, відповідний навіть відповідну логіку, а зробимо це Ну, найпростішим.
отримати це у вигляді звичайного джаоскрет масиву Ну і далі ми хочемо, повернути відповідні дані помогоджуй сону Ну скажімо, що це буде там.
Користочок.
Це сє.
юзерс вона отримає у всіх тих користувачів, які нас. Дає.
Ми хочемо додати. До неї. Ось до цього.
Діб'ю ж Так Простенько пагінація не буде нічим, за складна поки що Скажімо, ми його зробимо, наступним чином.
Створимо ще 1 елемент і вкажімо в ньому декілька кнопок Перша кнопка.
Це буде для того, щоб отримати.
От не з вами пиєш тобто попередні далі в нас буде.
Нубка Некс?
сторінки і давайте зробімо чинч бич щось щось такого типу.
І схожим чином зробимо до он клік.
Ельченська Річ.
маємо Декілька проблем. Перше: Ну, Ми знаємо нижній ліміт значень, пий Ми не можемо піти нижче нуля.
Скажімо, що, ми якщо на першій сторінці, та ми не Можемо, піти на півострові.
само ми використовуємо ма колекшн юзерс і просто використано метод.
Каутопія Вичте фільтр для ее підрахунку отримає кількість документів, які підпадають під відповідний фільтр фільтр не повинен не потрібен Тому ми просто будемо відправляти відповідний фільтр то наших христоч.
Для цього нам потрібно буде використати деякі функціонал. По-перше, нам треба розрахувати.
відповідну функцію, яка Ось Бачите, повертає найменший ціле число, більше ніж або рівне до того аргументи, який передали.
як?
Параметр і ми зможемо вже знати на якій ми зараз таку максимальну кількість сторінок ми можемо взагалі отримати з відповідного запиту.
Повертаючись до нашої функції. Давайте Тепер, обробляти все ж таки, те, що нам потрібно.
Давайте я словаю відповідні пункт, який ми розробляли до цього, і спробуємо сварити нову.
У нас. Це була поліція. Ченч. Палій Так.
Створимо всі пустою тим самим чином, створимо наступний.
А Чому так ми створили 2 функції, які фактично будуть нам?
Змінювати сторінки, тепер нам треба створити як хтось глобальних змін яка буде зберігати скажімо пейдж Тобто ми так, говоримо що ми на першій сторінці.
чогось наприклад, Нью-йорк, це буде нога нові користувачі якісь ми можемо користуватися Ось, цим прикладом, який ми використовували попередньо.
Для отримання г в даний момент давайте все ж таки мабуть, я приберу потребу в авторизації, тому що поки що нам це не потрібно тому давайте цей момент пропустимо.
Скопіюємо ось цю функцію. Ліє він ось тут додав а що буде там так не є зас приберемо фізичний код, який у нас тут.
А Добре. Тут бачите, воно Фактично, отримає всіх користувачів і просто буде відображати їх у відповідному списки так ми тут їх вправляли як Користувачі.
Так, у відповідному ж це Ми також.
Так треба буде Ось тут змінити трохи створимо тут зміну юзес тому що тепер наша відповідь від сервера має трохи більше значень, аніж попередньо тому треба її змінити відповідним чином щоб ми отримували користувачі тому що також ми повертаємо загальну кількість сторінок.
Тепер замінимо підно всюди ось таким чином, Добре, тепер коли ми успішно це зробив давайте спробуємо найпростішим чином.
А зробити запит причина в нас тут сторінка змінюється і ми використовуємо узерс для того, щоб її виконати так і Давайте ось тут.
Нью-йорксь.
Добре, тепер давайте спробуємо перевірити який у нас буде результат, зробити це досить просто є зараз паркчу.
Ось сюди на наш сайт і давайте спробуємо з вами. Оновили: сторінку питань ось бачите у нас з'явились попереднє і наступне.
Давайте натиснемо відкриємо панель для того щоб розуміти що таке відбувається так я мабуть, так я не запустив сервер вибачте зараз швиденько запустив і давайте спробуємо ще раз так у нас 403 доки неправильний я бачу що ось ми все ще робимо запит до користувачів.
А: я не зберіг сторінкою. Чичинав звісно Давайте ще раз. Спробуємо так? Бачимо що в нас ось 500 яка ж у нас помилка, кнод рід партію фантазія, що ми повернемось з вами то віжок, студію код і прочитаємо що ж таке це помилка.
Бачите що в нас, там виникло 2 помилок, перше, це живітть їх спая та вона неважливо, друга це ось тут, так я бачу, вона виникла в це мітубет тобто ось тут, мабуть, це тому що я не змінив так користувачі а добре давайте тоді спробуємо ще раз.
Так. 1 момент.
Переключу демонстрацію він Добре, Давайте спробуємо ще раз зробити відповідний запит 5 їм завжди бачимо що ми отримали з вами всіх користувачів.
І тут у пейчуть у нас пiг не любив А Чому ж так сталося. По-перше, як ви пам'ятаєте, у нас є потреба передавати відповідні, дані, розміру сторінки.
Тієї сторінки, на який ми зараз знаходимось у квітні Ось це Та є на мантефайн тому що ми намагаємось ділити фактично на 0 або ж не нічого для того, щоб ви правда?
присвоєно Відповідні змі повертаємось тільки то нашого менше мало і спробуємо зробити це ще раз о бачимо що ми отримали 5 користувачів, і бачимо, що ось у нас розрахувався тотал так я думаю, що це можна збільшити також у нас розрахувався тло-пай що у нас 3 загальної сторінки,
є у нас десь близько п'ятнадцяти скажімо, користувачів Ну, це число можна збільшити проте поки що будемо працювати із цим добре, тепер нам треба все ж таки, реалізувати відповідні кнопки, робити це можна досить просто повертаючись до нашої частини, з.
Ось нам треба тепер ми розраховуємо. З вами яка це є сторінка, Тобто даному випадку.
Ми за замовченню, вважаємо що ми на першій сторінці користувач скажімо не міг отримати їй якось інакше тому ми на перше, давайте спочатку зробимо функціонал щоб піти на нову сторінку тому ми фактично змінюємо просто поет і машина тут, вказати.
У нас є засобів учення Воно буде 1 просте.
То навіть простіше ми можемо чи ні, зробимо.
Некс бачимо, що ми отримували другу сторінку про те, я бачу. Нас нічого не змінилося.
Чому так сталося, як пам'ятаєте, ми маємо змінювати сторінки питання в нашій логіці?
Галузьє до отримання даних з.
у кількість даних, яку ми хочемо обробити Тобто, скільки ми хочемо пропустити найпростіший спосіб був би звідси домагатися це пейдж помножити на пейч-зас Проте проблема тут виникають в тому, що якщо в нас пч 1 апельс із 5 то ми отримаємо результат 5 а ми не хочемо
на першій сторінці пропускати 5 даних, ми просто робимо так що ми піднімаємо відповідь одиницю Тобто робимо її нуля, наприклад, і далі.
Множимо на печ сайз відповідно ми підтримуємо 0 але якщо наприклад, буде 1 то ми отримаємо 5 і таким чином, ми будемо отримувати число з якого ми маємо починати а тобто число рядків, з ваших бази даних яке буде пропущено.
Нудаємо відповідно ну тут скіт, ось бачите так нам ну нам пропонує якесь щось не те якийсь тест про те нам не важливо а ми будемо використовувати ось так і вказуємо кількість даних, які ми хочемо пропустити з результату, який ми отримаємо.
Так добре. Тепер давайте.
смертей користувачів які ми створюємо минулого разу, Як бачите в нас можна отримати ми отримали їх 3 Тобто, це остання сторінка і що буде якщо ми пишемо, 4 а ми не отримали нічого Ну, база даних, фактично на що у нас четверта сторінка тобто це 4 мінус 1, 3 і 3 помножте, на 5 це буде
15 а тому ми пропускаємо 15 записів, а більше 15 записів, у нас нічого і немає тепер все ж таки, давайте спробуємо перш ніж виправляти логічні помилки давайте спробуємо зробити ношу логіку печ Привіт все буде тим самим.
Просто фактично ви.
Зменшуємо сторінку на одиницю і отримаємо користувач.
Давайте спробуємо отримати, якщо ми клікнемо привіз то ми отримаємо нульову сторінку, а яка як бачите, нас навіть спрацювала.
І навіть якщо ми будемо далі у нас тепер помилки, тому що бачите, не може бути скіф меншим.
Нуля, а ми його фактично, вказуємо мінус 10. Взагалі Тобто, логіка нам треба все ж таки, робити якийсь захист тому, що бачите, сторінки пішли в мінус і сервер?
Ну не знаю, що з цим взагалі робити і можна було б звісно, зробити обмеження на сервері а для того, щоб уникнути цих помилок і давайте спробуємо це зробити це можна зробити з цього використано який очима буде перевіряти чи по пайч менше нуля.
відповідь. Можна скопіювати Ось такого типу?
Важливі зауваження бачите ми використовуємо ритм для того, щоб перервати все що йде далі тобто якщо ми ставимо моратюр то після цього рядка вже нічого не виконається ну кажемо що в нас там помилки скажімо ж там печ на тлі.
Менше одного не можу бути і Загалом, ту саму можна зробити обробку логіки для пейчсальз.
То якщо він там менше потрібно нулю то ми не хочемо, дозволяти це і скажімо, це таке, тому що розмір сторінки, не може бути налюби тоді у нас взагалі нічого не буде працювати, а ми не хочемо, цього допускати.
Добре, тепер давайте перезапустимо сервер.
Бачите? Користувач Може просто клікати? Якщо він не бачить помилки як даному випадку, можна так натискати і можна натискати на тексті вона буде збільшувати насправді в якийсь момент воно запрацює то можна сказати, що погано.
Працюю, проте не дуже і нам треба це все ж таки, виправити виправити. Це можна досить легко.
коли вони натискаються.
1 менше дорівнює нулю скажімо якимось чином то ми хочемо заборонити користувачу це робити і ми це зробимо досить просто взагалі це можна було б зробити набагато краще мабуть, давайте!
Документ Кет Елемент Бай Айті і наших Дiбу Передня кнопка.
Чудово, кози ми є І ось тут ми можемо змінити атрибути відповідний кнопки. Зробити.
Це можна досить легко. Використавши Нам треба тут. Має бути ісейд я думаю, що так мало.
Би спрацювати. Давайте спробуємо і тут. Каш фільмова Труд Тобто просто значення чи буде вона відключена чи ні?
нульову сторінку, навіть якщо сервер якимось чином це обробляє ми все ж таки, хочемо отримати так що немає в нас нульової сторінки тому що це фактично, сервер нам повертає першу сторінку, через помилки в обробці.
Тоді робимо ось тут тертюр.
Добре. І тепер промовив ще раз.
виправити відповідну помилку. Нам тоді треба перевіряти при кожному натисканні кнопки.
Яку кнопку нам можна розблокувати давайте створимо для цього відповідну функцію.
Ум: ченчек батись ці функції ми ж будемо перевіряти ще.
Обидві також працюється, у нас в нашому випадку, тому що нам треба не допустити щоб ми пішли наприклад, сюди, тому так нам треба буде мабуть, зробимо це трохи інакше.
Давайте десельту? Рибатом.
Ось так то створимо функцію в якій фактично ми будемо ее відключати відповідну кнопку, і давайте так само, зробимо це.
Не кспа.
І змінимо трохи в нас.
відключати кнопки, у випадках, коли навіть до умови ми залишимо цю умову яка в нас вона буде просто повертати і не катчу а от викликати пісеньку, привілей коли ми натискаємо на попередню, й те ж саме ми будемо робити зкс.
Добре, тоді давайте це ж таки, мабуть, так це немає сенсу. Давайте я їх просто поставлю годин, в одну функцію.
Таї на самий просто дiссей був Батонс немає Сенсу тримати їх у двох.
хочемо відключити кнопку.
А тут відповідно. Ми хочемо отримати.
Тут буде трохи складніша. Мова Перше нам потрібно знати, скільки нас сторінок взагалі є.
А тут ми це можемо, робити створимо, тут зміну тотал печис скажімо, і вона там буде поки що дорівнювати мінус 1 так і тут ми вкажемо, що вона буде вимкнена якщо там.
Скажімо, поч.
зробити їх пунктними. За замовчу поки ми не отримаємо відповідні дані так буде простіше і не будемо додавати ніяких умов, і давайте перевіримо що пейдж мінус 1 скажемо, менше або дорівнює тото pace Тобто, якщо скажімо, поїдьтесь дорівнює трьом га так мабуть, це ж без мінус
некс бачимо що нас блокували кнопку привіз і тепер ми ось зробили з вами таку найпростішу пагінацію так я бачу, що умова. Не працює відповідних то я неправильно назвав це бачите, то то печис.
може натиснути відповідно.
Давайте тепер натисніть привіз і Бачите, нас. Повертаємось легко. І ми можемо лише одного від одного до трьох.
Можна Звісно, додати? Нас третій Бачите, сторінці. В нас всього. 2 даних ми можемо додати?
Щось там Перше кіно 1 Ейнi Йосиф так? Тінь Єзартва мі за 3 лі'юзор 4 для цього ми робили те що ми робимо запит кожен раз, до себе тому що фактично можна зробити поєднання декілька компонентів а перший спосіб це ви отримаєте всі дані на частині фронтенду а тут ви 4 мене раз,
тут і далі. Ви просто пере користувачу показуєте ці дані і По сторінково проте проблема цього підходу якщо в нас багато даних то вони не будуть будуть По-перше, довго збиратись А по-друге вони будуть.
Занадто проблемачними для подальшої обробки і третє це те, що скажімо, якщо, це система, в якій працює декілька пристроїв.
блог Давайте ми додали Ось декілька користувачів. І Давайте спробуємо натиснути некст і бачимо, що у нас тут лпед змінився тепер до чотирьох і ми можемо динамічно бачити ми тепер вже на третій сторінці і наша пагінація Чудово.
До Зміни розміру сторінки. Ми залу можемо спробувати це забезпечити Давайте додамо всі йдуть веч.
З вами Як бачите, ми з вами зробили такий мінімальний, приклад Можна сюди додати функціонал.
Сенс дорівнює ну, скажімо, 2 і подивимось, як все ж зміниться. Наш та обробник повертаємось до нашого пару оновлюємо натискаємо кет і бачимо, що у нас вже змінилось?
Тото pele- до дев'яти тобто у нас розмір сторінки успішно.
Працює. Його можна істи отримаємо так само хімі ми йдемо до рівно якраз дев'ятої сторінки така в нас є остання зараз сайти, є досить популярне робити варіативний розмір сторінки.
Тобто ви можете обирати можна додати від поля управляються розмірами сторінки та кількість поле які ми дозволяємо на даному етапі в нас нема потреби і блоги частіше за все не реалізують таку можливість.
Добрий? Я бачу, що в нас якраз лишається 5 хвилин на запитання, Можливо, які є сумно, цього тому що починати щось нове у нас немає сенсу, а з пагнацією, Як бачите, ми досить швидко за 45 хвилин.
Впоралися з досить Складною темою в веб-розробці.
То можливо, є якісь запитання. Щось незрозуміло.
консультація.
Добре можемо або понеділок це ж від того, як вас бути по заняттях або Віктор.
Або можемо організувати Станіславом Якщо в інших немає питань, то можемо в телеграмі зв'язатись як вам та хлопці Станіслава.
Я Гадаю, що це дуже гарна опція. А раз. Це узгоджено. Мовчання ознака згоди буде добровільно, причому, виходить, так гарна ідея.
До захисту робіт. Вчора ввечері наукові керівники доповіли, що власне, усі таки зможуть подолати цей бар'єр.
Буде сьогодні спробувати завершити користуючись випадком, я позробляю групу, із стовідсотковим допуском.
Ну, це гарна ідея. Давайте цілеспрямоване до цього йти перший крок що нам необхідно як це називається подолати нашу наступну п'ятницю.
Дякую. Велике.
Дякую. І До зустрічі на все добре.
Дякую вам також. Гарного дня До побачення.
В мене До побачення.